how to get to the point in conversation
by the end of this video i'm going to be
sharing tools with you that will help
save you time fluffing around in
conversation also increase and build a
culture of psychological safety and make
you a far better leader and educator by
increasing your clarity as well i'm chad
littlefield
let's get to the point
[Music]
so first i want to share about some
world-renowned leaders that when you
hear and think of the way that they
navigate and get to the point in
conversations it'll blow your mind a
little bit i then want to share a really
practical tool that you can use as an
anchor in any meeting any conversation
to always get back to the point because
the problem is that sometimes
conversations wander and so even if you
get to the point of something
you go down a rabbit hole and you got to
get back to the point and so i'll give
you a tool that will serve as an anchor
that no matter where you are in
conversation no matter how long you've
worked with a group no matter how long
you've been in conversation you can get
back to the point using this tool and
then i want to combine wisdom from two
of my mentors that entered one each side
of my brain and formed a absolutely
brilliant strategy to actually cut a
conversation in half and separate out
the fluff from the heart of the matter
jesus buddha gandhi and rosa parks
can you imagine
any of these
four
leaders figures historical
beings
walking into a room and saying hey how
was your weekend
i'm sure they probably did it i'm sure
they probably chatted about you know
stuff the superfluous chit chat of life
but these are people and some of the
best most renowned leaders are masters
of getting to the heart of what matters
and here's their secret they had such a
strong and compelling and clear purpose
and intention that it rang through and
emanated from everything they said and
did if you want to elevate your ability
to get to the heart of the matter
be as intentional and purposeful as them
you know priya parker says meet for
purpose not for time how often are you
in a conversation and you're not exactly
sure why until you're like halfway
through it or something meeting for
purpose not for time and stating your
intention always in the first few
minutes of a conversation
is your anchor it's like you tossing an
anchor to the point to what you want to
get done what you want to discuss or
what you want to solve or unpack or
whatever else
it's the anchor and so anytime you go
off
path
you can come back to it second tool that
my uh once upon a time mentor now
business partner will wise shared with
me is this idea that this metaphor
steering into the curve now this is he
didn't invent this metaphor and uh if
you have never gotten in a car accident
it's a little bit hard to relate to or
if you've never been skidding around off
an accident ramp it's a little bit hard
to relate to but imagine that you're
going off an extra ramp and your car
your tires lose friction you start
sliding the best thing you can possibly
do in that tense moment is actually
steer into
the curve meaning turn the wheel the way
that looks like it's going to make you
crash harder and worse
and that's actually the way to get out
of that slide now you know before you
fully implement that maybe google
another video about extreme driving to
you know check that the idea here is the
metaphor uh if you want to get to the
heart of the matter you've got to steer
into it so often i see conversations uh
or i hear secondhand or even third hand
about a conversation of he said she said
whatever where people are trying to get
to the heart of the matter
in this roundabout way and you just you
just can't like it just it leads to
passive aggressive communication almost
every time and so cutting to the heart
of the matter what i would invite you to
do is point out the elephant in the room
in fact one of my mentors eric tyler who
wrote a book called the best advice so
far and so i do think this is kind of
the best advice so far he said that once
you say something half the power leaves
it
or once you say something half the
awkwardness leaves it i think that's
true and valuable to keep in mind when
you're trying to get to the heart of the
matter because oftentimes we feel like
oh like i can't get to the point because
it's too like
raw it's too there's too much conflict
in bed in it there's two that we have
some fear around just cutting straight
to it i'm saying like this is what we
need to talk about right now and yet
oftentimes as soon as we say it as soon
as we speak it out half the power leaves
it right there and then it becomes a
conversation you can talk about it the
longer that you try to dance around a
topic to try to get to this or to try to
hint at right so let's let's make this
concrete with an example let's say you
have an employee who is just not
performing well they're not doing a good
job either you can complement their work
and and point out the good things that
they do
do or you can sit them down and say hey
my expectation is actually that this
role is here this is gonna maybe be an
uncomfortable conversation
but you're actually totally not meeting
expectations right now however
and this is where intention comes in as
an anchor however i would really love to
work with you to meet those expectations
if you're willing if you're interested
so do you see how we pointed out
something that was really hard we ripped
a band-aid off but we also came back
around and said i want to be on your
team though
will you be on my team and that that's
the intention part of this when your
intention includes the needs of others
and actually benefits other people you
can rip as many band-aids as you want
off if your intentions are to uplift
that person now if you want to get to
the heart of the matter and your
intention has that actually ripped
somebody down
then you can't or there's no way to hide
that or fluff that like you know giving
feedback in the um the sandwich format
of i'll give good feedback and then bad
feedback and then good feedback not
really that useful now everything i
showed up to this point is useful but
what i'm about to share with you is like
is it it's it's the golden gem it's the
nugget it's uh what separates uh really
great facilitators from like okay
facilitators it is the ability to
recognize that there is always something
happening while something is happening
which sounds kind of ridiculous but
track with me for a minute so in a
conversation
there's two levels that are happening up
here there's content there's what you're
actually saying there's the words that
are being said
the sentences that are being strung
together and then
all the while that's that conversation's
going on there's something happening and
i would call that process and process is
literally everything else it's all the
music behind the words it's the unspoken
emotions it's the unsaid thoughts it's
the uh tensioner dynamic between these
two people it's the past comment that
somebody said somebody's still holding a
grudge against right all the whole pro
all team dynamics right it's the fact
that uh only men are speaking in a
meeting and there's no opportunity for
anybody else to speak or only people at
the top of the hierarchy are speaking
and there's no invitation for the
quieter folks or the folks further down
on the rung right all those dynamics
that's process and if you want to get to
the point in conversation become a
master at oscillating between the two go
down to process bring it whatever is
happening or whatever you're noticing up
into the content and actually talk about
it so take a break from the content of
your meeting
to bring process and say hey everybody
this is happening right now what do we
want to do about it or you can make a
decision hey this is happening right now
i'm recognizing that only 3 out of 10 of
you are really contributing
and we're not leaving much space and the
three of us aren't leaving much space
for the seven of you to contribute and
so i'd actually love to take five
minutes to fully pause and write down
our thoughts about this and then i'd
love to hear the voices
that haven't been heard so far right so
you duck down into process you bring it
up and you acknowledge and steer right
into that curve right into that dynamic
it's oscillating between content and
process if you want to deep dive in
content process in the last chapter of
ask powerful questions me and will's
book
we unpack some advanced tools on how to
create conversations that matter this
last chapter could be a book of its own
it's so densely rich with really
practical tools to help your gatherings
be so much better i'm chad littlefield
have an awesome day